il faudra t'il travailler plus pour
reconstruire l'économie laminée par le
commis de 10,9 au fil de ses
interventions
emmanuel macron semble le penser mais
n'y at-il pas un paradoxe a demandé aux
français de travailler plus alors que le
chômage monte lui en flèche
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex de
nos studios de caumartin bonsoir jacques
av
bonsoir cette année alors j'ai avec le
président maquereau a récemment rappelé
que les français étaient parmi ceux en
europe qui travaillait le moins que
faut-il penser de son injonction à
travailler plus vers le stéphanie c'est
effectivement en effet ce de lieux
communs qui a repris le président macron
les français travailleraient moins que
leurs voisins et surtout moins longtemps
que nos voisins ce n'est pas exactement
ce que disent les chiffres
par ailleurs on peut se demander si le
problème n'est pas que les français
travaillent peut-être mieux qu'un
certain nombre d'autres
et puis la troisième question c'est
évidemment celle du rapport avec la
montée du chômage que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est ce que ça a vraiment un
sens de dire qu'il faut travailler plus
quand on a de plus en plus de chômeurs
angeac qu'en est il des chiffres alors
stéphanie vous savez l'oscd ne tient
justement des statistiques régulièrement
sur cette question et on voit que les
français qui sont connus pour bénéficier
effectivement des 35 heures
1 un certain nombre de congés payés et
bien c'est français il travaille
beaucoup regardé justement ces
statistiques
vous voyez les français travaillent plus
que les allemands que les néerlandais
vous savez ces gens de l'europe du nord
que l'on dit justement très travailleur
banon les français travaillent plus
par contre il travaille peut-être un
petit peu moins que les italiens ou les
espagnols alors jacques qu'en est-il au
sein des populations françaises
alors vous avez tout à fait raison de
poser cette question stéphanie parce
qu'on voit bien que suivant les
professions la durée du travail varie
beaucoup
prenons par exemple le cas des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs
travaillent pratiquement 60 heures par
semaine
les professions libérales les artisans
les petits chefs d'entreprises
travaillent eux aussi beaucoup bon même
les ouvriers et les employés travaillent
sensiblement plus que 35 heures par
semaine
donc il faut comprendre que 35 heures
c'est une durée légale mais que la durée
réelle du travail
elle est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
proche de 40 heures alors junte est-il
vrai comme l'affirmé emmanuel macron que
les français travaillent moins longtemps
sur l'ensemble de leur carrière
alors ça c'est fini ça pose la question
parce qu'on appelle le taux d'activité
pour la tranche d'âge de 55 à 64 ans et
là encore l' ocde tient des statistiques
qui sont particulièrement précises
si vous regardez les chiffres vous
constatez que les français sont un peu
de choses près au même niveau que
justement les italiens les espagnols
par contre il ya effectivement quelques
pays en particulier la des pays d'europe
nord comme les pays bas ou l'allemagne
où ce taux d'activité est plus élevé
alors comment expliquez vous cela
et bien en réalité stéphanie ce que l'on
voit là c'est tout simplement l'effet du
chômage en effet le chômage on le sait
il touche soit les jeunes qui rentrent
sur le marché du travail et qu'il
n'arrive pas à justement à rentrer sur
le marché du travail soient les plus de
50 ans où les plus de 55 ans qui sont
parmi les premiers qui sont licenciés et
c'est très exactement ce qui fait la
différence aujourd'hui entre la france
et des pays comme les pays bas ou
l'allemagne
c'est l'importance du chômage en france
qui pousse les entreprises
justement à licencier ou à pousser vers
des mises à la retraite anticipée tous
les personnels qui ont plus de 55 ans il
devient en france extrêmement dur de
trouver du travail quand on est
considéré comme un travailleur seniors
alors nouveau la ramener au problème du
chômage d'où notre question de départ
dans un pays qui a plus de 11 % de
chômeurs suivant en ligne
est-ce que cela a un sens de dire aux
gens justement qu'il faut travailler
davantage
évidemment non stéphanie évidemment non
si vous voulez le problème c'est que si
on veut que les gens de plus de 55 ans
travaille plus et travaillent plus
longtemps surtout il faut leur donner du
travail
or nous sommes justement dans une
situation que celle inverse où il y a
moins de travail pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui les entreprises
elle parle de quoi elle parle de plans
sociaux elle parle de licencier pas
d'embauché donc on voit très bien il n'y
a pas de sens à dire il faut travailler
plus longtemps alors oui si l'on pose
peut-être la question de manière un
petit peu différent alors justement
quelle signification pardon jacques
j'étais impatient de savoir quelles
significations cachées
tout est fait vous aviez raison d'être
impatient parce que qu'est-ce qui va se
jouer par exemple admettons que de par
la loi
on repousse la durée légale du travail à
65 ans à 66 ans c'est pas pour autant
que les gens vont travailler plus en
fait
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui sera mis au
chômage à 60 61 62 63 ans
et bien il ne touchera pas sa retraite
complète
il aura ce qu'on appelle une décote et
on peut se demander si ce n'est pas cela
que vise en réalité
emmanuel macron autrement dit non pas
faire travailler plus les gens il n'en a
pas les moyens
puisque nous sommes dans une situation
où le chômage augmente mais bien de
diminuer les pensions de retraite
l art en conclusion jacques à vous
pensez que c'est
la seule raison alors c'est en tous les
cas la seule raison qui serait rationnel
mettons de côté évidemment la
possibilité que ce ne soit qu'un thèmes
idéologiques la seule raison qui
aujourd'hui est rationnel c'est que le
gouvernement veut faire baisser les
pensions de retraite il veut en réalité
finir de mettre en oeuvre cette fameuse
réforme des retraites qu'il a dû
interrompre le temps de l'épidémie du
coup vite 19 et que ce soit emmanuel
macron par exemple dans son interview à
la presse quotidienne régionale
où que ce soit jean castex les deux ont
dit qu'ils voulaient la reprendre en
réalité on voit bien ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui c'est une baisse des
pensions de retraite et bien jacques si
on comprend bien il va falloir se
retrousser les manches
merci à vous et à bientôt sur rt france